Between July 25 and September 23, 2001, the
people of the southern India state of Kerala
witnessed, on numerous occasions an extraordinary
sight: blood colored rain.
Although most reports limited the color of
the rain to that striking red that resembled
blood, some people also reported seeing green,
black and even yellow rain as well.
Eye-witnesses also reported that accompanying
the early instances of colored rain were loud
thunderclaps and flashes of lighting.
And following the weird rain’s first appearance,
many trees shed their leaves, with the leaves
turning grey and appearing to be burned.
Whether any of these reports were exaggerated
or not, the colored rain was a scientific
curiosity and, as scientists are wont to do,
they got to studying the phenomenon.
Early on it was determined that in each milliliter
of rain, about 9 million red particles could
be found.
However, perhaps corroborating the stories
of those who reported other colored rain,
it was found that while most particles were
red, there were some that were tinted green,
bluish grey and yellow.
The Centre for Earth Science Studies in Kerala,
which learned that the pH of the rain was
neutral, also found it had large amounts of
nickel, manganese, titanium, chromium and
copper.
The red particles, themselves, were determined
to be mostly carbon and oxygen with small
amounts of iron and silicon.
This led the Centre to at first attribute
the likely cause of the colored rain to an
exploding meteor; however, further research
showed the particles contained spores.
While there was quite a bit of hoopla over
some researchers speculating the spores may
have had extraterrestrial origin, given initial
reports of lack of any DNA found and some
still going with the “exploding meteor”
idea, in fact, the Tropical Botanical Garden
and Research Institute eventually found that
the particles were spores of “a lichen-forming
alga belonging to the genus Trentepohlia”
that they believed came from local sources.
They opined that heavy rains preceding the
events triggered widespread growth of the
lichens, which in theory would have increased
the number of spores in the air.
However, while that was their best guess,
they noted they thought it unlikely that the
lichens would simultaneously release enough
spores to account for the colored rain.
They further were baffled at how the spores
would have risen so high in the atmosphere
as no nearby, recent weather phenomenon seemed
a likely culprit to have caused such an upswell.
Approximately a decade and a half after the
event, some of the mystery may have been solved.
In 2013, scientists continuing to study the
event, not only found the missing DNA, but
not long after researchers revealed that the
precise species of the algae was Trentepohlia
annulata, which was not native to India, hence
explaining why no local weather phenomenon
around that time explained how the spores
got so high in the atmosphere.
The researchers ultimately speculated that
the spores were introduced through the clouds
from Austria.
Of course, weird rains are nothing knew to
history.
As we’ve covered before, Kentucky even had
a Cloudy with the Chance of Meatballs-like
rain in 1876 when chunks of meat literally
rained from the sky.
Moving more recently in history, in early
2015, a strange, milky rain fell on parts
of Idaho, Oregon and Washington.
Scientists eventually learned it was caused
by a dust storm from southern Oregon, where
the dust had a “high amount of saline, similar
to the composition of milk.”
Going back to relatively ancient times, Greek
philosopher Heraclides Lembus (2nd century
BCE) recorded a rain that included so many
frogs falling from the sky, “the houses
and the roads have been full of them.”
While you might think this couldn’t have
actually happened, in better documented times
(2005), a small town in Serbia had a rain
of non-native frogs, some of which survived.
The primary hypothesis for why frogs (or fish,
snakes, stones, meat or maggots) occasionally
fall from the sky is that waterspouts or tornadoes
suck them up and then drop them somewhere
else.
While the hypothesis hasn’t been definitively
proven for small animal rain, it’s not unheard
of for small-animal sized objects to be picked
up by tornadoes and then travel even as far
as 50-200 miles before being deposited back
on solid ground.
Note, too, when talking extremely light objects,
like large dust particles, these have been
documented travelling thousands of miles and
falling in rain, including yellow dust from
the Gobi Desert falling on Washington state
in 1998 (~5600 miles or 9000 km), and Saharan
dust travelling across the Atlantic Ocean.